clearly he set up this entire scenario
so that he would have an audience maybe
this is why he first appeared on that
mysterious VHS tape 6 years prior he
wants people to watch him do the
terrible things he does he's a clown and
a mime after all clowns and mimes need
audiences to perform in front of even
the way the sheet is set up before
revealing Dawn almost looks like a stage
curtain by making his kills more
gruesome and hard for others to watch
art maybe gets more out of it for
himself of course with Showmanship also
comes drama art is putting on a show and
the fact that he forces Tera to watch
gives us a clue as to his motivation she
would soon find that she is his literal
captive audience and that the show was
only just
beginning